hello America and the world
my name is Gregory what is your name
madam I am Jesse look at orto Jesse look
at ya okay that's close okay Jesse uh if
you guys have ever seen the channel
sweet eats with reoccurring reject Monet
Moya
you would see that she is on every one
of the videos as well she is the co-host
co-creator of sweets as well if you want
to get healthy in a delicious way
sweeties
anyway I invited her here today and I
thought you know what if we're gonna do
a reaction together we're gonna start
off strong really strong my friend Jesse
have you ever heard of the channel rack
Careca I have not okay
well they do sketches all right
let me tell you see how you respond
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
nice
I'm not sure the feeling things are
about to get really well we ruined the
placard the millions
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
what
wait I don't like this
[Laughter]
[Music]
like just give me five minutes
so yeah just
that's uh that's rack of racket they
tend to do sketches well yeah like
watery ice cream oh my god yeah they
tend to do sketches that start off like
oh this is funny then they get really
violent they've done worse raunchy
they've done some way worse I love it
because it's like that there's so many
prank videos on YouTube and there's such
an argument all the time about which
channels do fate drinks and which ones
are real are there even real pranks
anymore and the Sam pepper wanted you
ever see that one this is genius
it's genius you never saw this this Sam
pepper prank where uh where they gotta
watch it's where these two dudes get
taken hostage and one of the dudes is in
on the prank but the guy isn't on the
prank gets shot in the head and dies and
the other is terrifying these people are
crazy
ya know me what's cool about Iraq Iraq
because you just started off doing like
just fun stuff I actually got to meet
them one time at VidCon oh well they're
really cool dudes I hear they have like
an actual movie going on or the channel
Universal Studios and this inspiring cuz
these guys just put together these fun
sketches and they still keep it and
they're creative fun I like it and now
they're getting movie offers and they do
their own stunts and they're they take
advantage of their budgets getting
better like collects like car stuff like
brings like they go out oh yeah it's
crazy I'd love to be in one of their
videos
I think Jess would be great a mother
that would be a beautiful disaster
disaster yeah face up what should be is
like they mug you like they will mock
you and then they get dragged they found
you in the face your teeth fall out you
swallow some of your tonight me up to
the car and drive away tie up to the car
driveway
face down serious they put someone
between two cars and they rip her apart
Oh hate that in movies I know they do
that at one minute oh yeah where you
feel the spine break yeah that's so
painful I hate the sound effects will
they oh excuse me anyway yeah I'd love
to see that happen to you anyway yeah
raka raka that's the channel subscribe
to them and watch more of their crazy
ass videos I have some really violent
it's like not even funny
this is violent but yeah I love to flats
and use kneeling at me in one of your
videos so would yes yeah she would love
to have her can't wait
ripped off yeah you know it can be it
can be on a first date and he's actually
a serial killer so the whole time
they're just doing horrible things to
Jess it's like Dexter oh yeah and this
great cartoon
listen human beings don't don't sarcasm
me you listen
homies and friends and african-americans
and those people that Trump is trying to
keep away from this country if you're
new to this channel this American
channel subscribe today join the
subscription services of all those that
become rejects Jess Lucan aqua is on
sweet eats YouTube channel she also has
an Instagram right that you used to use
anything else I don't it is that thing
was it called hot water Twitter are you
making a joke
tweeter making it sugar water Twitter
are you on Twitter yeah I'm on Twitter I
got
I tweet about personal things real
personal things
what is that for you oh it's great it's
a great way to get my personal life out
there create some online drama I've
recently been diagnosed with chlamydia
oh that's good to tell the world I know
they should know well what I'm trying to
do is you know I don't want to like have
people come on the show especially when
a female guest comes on and have them
think like I'm coming on to them so I
like to start off with hey I got
chlamydia and we shouldn't even really
shake hands because I hear it might be
contagious that way through any touch
any touch any touch no bugs yeah a
little bit of bubble
that's what chlamydia does to you people